foreign
comes from Ruth in Virginia my debit
card has fraught has had fraud two times
in a two-week period
it's time consuming to change all the
auto payments and to get a new card some
people say that credit cards are harder
for thieves to do fraud than on a debit
card what is your experience and opinion
with this is there any truth to that
theory also some people recommend using
a credit card for all purchases and
paying it off at the end of the month I
know that you advise against doing that
method can you shed some light onto why
this is an unwise method
happy to I love that you called it a
theory because that's honestly what it
is I'm going to be honest with you you
asked for my opinion and my experience I
have never ever had problems with using
a debit card and I have experienced much
fraud
um you know there's been plenty of times
where I saw the guy I saw the
transactions from Best Buy popping up uh
on my screen as it was happening around
Christmas time and I just called the
bank and I said someone's got my
information this is a fraud fraudulent
purchase I mean lickety-split the money
was back in my account and you can look
and I was just talking with Dave about
this you know I think a lot of people
get hung up because if you look at some
of these acts the electronic funds
transfer act you know and and some of
these things it'll say there's some
slight differences but at the end of the
day the actual contract on your
MasterCard right on that that trumps
that and it's zero liability it's the
same if you look up MasterCard and visa
and look at the actual agreement online
for it says for debt red cards and
credit cards
you have the exact same fraud protection
you have zero liability zero zero now if
your debit card in a two-week period
has you had fraud two times your credit
card would have had fraud two times
because wherever you're using that thing
is being picked up somewhere
it just means somebody has your
information no and if I get your credit
card information you're gonna have to
change your credit card same thing
you're going to get the same phone call
from the same bank and they're going to
say we have activity that does not look
like it is your normal activity and
we're going to stop all charges until we
verify this you get that from debit
cards you get that from credit cards
with my bank it's an automated thing
they call up and I have to push one and
I have to push about three things now I
verify that verify that verify that so
you know I was down in Mexico Cabo a few
weeks ago and they're like what are you
doing in Mexico you're a hillbilly and
I'm like so they should you know weird
charge we're charged we're charged and
I'm like no not wear charge it was me
I'm here and so yeah but that's that the
algorithms follow the pattern of the
purchases for a debit card or a credit
card because here's the thing
in either case
credit card or debit card you are not
liable for a transaction that was not
yours if you have a Visa or a MasterCard
product that is their agreement with you
period
so in either case if Best Buy or I don't
know whatever place in taco bar or
Mexico right uh is showing up that means
somebody got your number and it wasn't
you in this case it was me in your case
it wasn't you but if they if they let
that money go yeah the bank lets that
money go out of your account if it's a
debit card or just against your credit
card they can't get it back they lose
money that's right so in in and they
lose the exact the same money on a
credit card fraud as they lose on a
debit card fraud and so they run the
same theft and fraud algorithms to track
to see if you're doing it's no different
it's no different so if you don't like
having to change everything and get a
new card with all your auto payments uh
with a debit card you're gonna have the
exact same thing happen with your credit
card it has nothing to do with debit or
credit has to do with where you're using
the stupid thing right you're running
somewhere where somebody's picking the
thing up
and you need to look at your somewhere
you're going where somebody's got a
fraud reader or something a card reader
that's a stuck in the thing and uh where
your passwords suck something somebody's
getting your information I know some of
the guys around here they like
privacy.com because you can buy things
online and you can basically use uh
Incognito card so they're never seeing
your information so that's an option for
people who are looking but I like the
and I kind of want to address Dave the
the second part of this question which
is saying some people recommend and I
this is again this is the thing that
everybody is doing and since everybody's
doing it
don't do it which is I put all my
purchases for the month on my credit
card just to make it easy Dave so I
don't have to think about it you know I
just go to the store swipe it and then
at the end of the month I can just pay
it off when my check comes in I put all
my purchases on my debit card and comes
out my checking account
what's the difference well one day oh I
just used my money that's all
you're going to use your money to pay it
off yeah it's Dumber though you have to
have your brain turned on it's
absolutely dumber than a rock
you don't want to have your brain turned
on you want to just be able to swipe it
and not think about it
I don't want to think about my money and
I want to have some but yeah magically
moronic yet magically you'll have just
enough from your paycheck to pay it off
that well we know that's wrong let me
help you with this we know that's not
the case people who don't think about
money don't have any that's how this
works a trillion dollars Dave of credit
card debt that's what we're at you know
we're new record new record in card debt
too and the default rate is Sky High you
know what
me and you we got a long career head up
we sure do